Hey, it's Michael Valtos here from Order
Flows and let me ask you something
honest and I want you to really think
about this before you answer. How many
times have you seen a delta divergence
clear as day, textbook perfect, and
still hesitated? Not because you didn't
see it. You saw it. You know what delta
divergence looks like. You hesitated
because you weren't sure if that one
signal was enough. Or how about this?
You see stacked imbalances forming,
three levels of aggressive buying. Looks
incredible, so you enter long and the
market drops 15 points through your stop
like it wasn't there.
Or maybe this is your version. You see a
beautiful setup, delta divergence at a
key level, but you also see imbalances
going the other direction and the volume
profile is showing something else
entirely. Now you have three signals and
they're all saying different things. So
what do you do? You freeze. You wait.
You watch the trade play out exactly the
way you thought it would without you. I
see this with traders every single day
and here's why it happens.
You've learned order flow in pieces. You
know, one course taught you about delta,
another course taught you about volume
profile, and maybe you watched some
YouTube videos about imbalances, and now
you got all these individual skills, but
nobody ever taught you how they fit
together.
Think about it. Every order flow course
you've taken teaches you what delta is,
what imbalances are, what a point of
control is. That's like teaching someone
chess by explaining how each piece
moves. The rook goes straight, the
bishop goes diagonal, but never showing
them an actual opening, an actual
strategy, an actual end game pattern.
You know how the pieces move, but you
don't know how to play the game and
that's the gap I'm closing today.
Here's what I learned from 20 years of
institutional trading and I mean really
learned from sitting on the desk
trading, not from a textbook. At JP
Morgan, at Commerzbank, at Cargill, we
never looked at one data point in
isolation, ever.
Nobody on institutional desks says,
"Delta's diverging. Let's put on a
position." That would get you laughed
out of the room. Every trade decision
was a synthesis. You looked at the price
action context. You looked at where you
were in the volume distribution. You
looked at who was aggressive and who was
passive in the order flow and you made a
decision based on the convergence of all
of it.
But here's the thing. When I left the
institutional world and started teaching
retail traders, I realized something
that genuinely surprised me. Nobody was
teaching the combinations.
Every course, every book, every YouTube
channel, they all teach order flow
concepts one at a time. Delta in this
module, imbalances in the next module,
volume profile in a separate course
entirely. And then traders are left to
figure out the hard part, how these
pieces fit together completely on their
own.
That's like giving someone all the
ingredients for a Michelin star meal,
but no recipe. You've got the flour, the
eggs, the butter, but without the recipe
that tells you how to combine them, in
what order, and at what temperature,
you're just guessing. The Advanced Order
Flow Trading Encyclopedia Part 3 is the
recipe book.
So let me show you what's exactly inside
Part 3. So Part 3 contains 66 specific
documented
combination trade setups. Every single
one of these combines a minimum two and
often all three of these analytical
dimensions such as price action together
with the order flow or volume profile
together with the order flow or
Fibonacci analysis with order flow.
And each trade is
chart is shown, it's documented, it's
it's explained in a video as well in
written instructions for you. So every
single one of these
66 setups is explained for you in a
video breakdown. Not a recycled webinar,
not a screen recording from 3 years ago.
These are fresh focused video
walkthroughs that I recorded
specifically for Part 3. In each video,
I take you inside a real market example
and walk you through the entire
combination, what the order flow is
showing, what the volume profile
structure tells you, what the price
action is confirming, and exactly how
they come together to create the trade.
You also get the specific trigger
conditions for each setup, so you know
precisely what to look for before,
during, and after entry. You get the
confirmation signals, so there's no
ambiguity about when the setup is valid.
And you get the context, which market
conditions favor each setup, when to
expect it, and when to avoid it. Look,
this isn't a course you watch once and
put on a shelf. This is a reference
encyclopedia you have open every single
trading day.
Look, I know there are a lot of people
selling trading education and I know
you've probably been burned before. So
let me just lay out the facts and you
can decide for yourself. You know, I
started in 1994 on the CME trading floor
at Dean Witter. I traded for JP Morgan.
I traded for Commerzbank. I traded for
Cargill. I traded for EDF Man. These
aren't companies I visited on a tour on
a 6-week internship.
These are desks where I sat every day
executing real institutional orders with
real capital. I've taught order flow to
thousands of traders through
orderflows.com. Parts 1 and 2 of this
encyclopedia series have been used by
traders all over the world. The feedback
on those have been incredible. But
honestly, the best proof isn't what I
tell you, it's what happens when you
start seeing these combinations in real
time on your charts. When you spot a
triple convergence setup for the first
time and watch it play out exactly the
way the encyclopedia describes it,
that's the moment you know this is
different.
So here's what it comes down to. You can
keep trading single signals. You can
keep guessing whether that delta
divergence is enough on its own. You can
keep watching setups play out after
you've already talked yourself out of
them. Or you can start trading the way
institutions trade with multiple data
points converging into
one high conviction decision. The
Advanced Order Flow Trading Encyclopedia
Part 3 gives you 66 of those decisions
documented, explained, ready to trade.
Single signals lie. Combinations tell
the truth. It's time to start trading
the truth. Click the button, get in, and
I'll see you on the inside.